greetings everyone this is rob sanders
from simply learn happy new year
and today we're going to talk about
digital marketing skills
so digital marketing allows business
owners
regardless of the business non-profit
for-profit large or small
national local international to really
expand their business
allows them to personalize their content
they could save money
and most importantly they can measure
the results and so that's what we're
going to focus
on today we talk about digital marketing
skills
focusing on measuring those results
so i suppose anybody wants to work
in marketing or grow a company or help
grow
an individual's company or ensure to
keep up with the appropriate skills
this is what we're going to cover today
so we're going to cover a few channels
and so let's get right to it today we're
going to start off with
search engine optimization or seo
also known as organic search so seo
is an interesting channel it's probably
the premier channel for most companies
in fact hubspot confirms that 57
of b2b marketers stated that seo
generates more leads than any other
marketing initiative
so it's really important for not only
just generating traffic
but it's also important for generating
leads and
generating more business including
e-commerce
and so what does seo entail and what
skills should you
acquire in order to manage seo as a
marketing channel
well if you think about it seo is really
divvied up into two
pies one pie is called on page
the other pie is called off page and so
on page
consists of things you can do to the
website
to help you be found in organic search
so what are those things well it could
be anything from
you know page load speed to four or four
errors to site maps and so the point
here
is if you're going to manage seo and you
know
that you got to make sure your website's
in tip top shape or your clients
websites and
good enough shape for google to
recognize it as a legitimate site
you have to have some technical skills
now i'm not saying you have to be
developer
but at the same time you have to know
what a 4-4 error is you don't have to
know
where and how to generate a site map and
upload that sitemap
you need to know how to edit a robot's
text file
so those are you know what i call soft
technical skills but they're all
valid for seo so you have to have some
technical background
staying in the on-page pie okay
you need to make sure you have not only
skills to write content but skills to
optimize content so you need to be aware
of all the different elements on a page
in order to optimize that page so again
that entails
you know some copywriting skills but
more importantly
and probably more challenging is to take
those copywriting skills and enhance
them
for seo okay so making sure that you're
able to understand
what it is that you need to do to get a
page optimized so it can rank
higher in the search engine results
so those are on page skills and then you
got the other piece of the pie which is
off page
so understanding you know what it takes
to make sure your site is relevant
so it's understanding different metrics
off-page
metrics like page authority domain
authority external links
internal links and so generally most seo
managers have a
third-party seo platform that they work
with like
sem rush or moz so it's understanding
how to work with those
platforms to measure off page results
so we always say that seo as a digital
marketing channel is an 800 pound
gorilla well
it is because you have on page and off
page to worry about so the two of those
together
you know is is quite a task in order to
rank
and so what brings seo and all digital
marketing channels
is understanding the metrics and
understanding
what you're seeing in order to measure
results
and improve upon those results so that's
really the theme for all these digital
marketing channels we're going to talk
about today
it's really about okay what metrics and
how do i measure the results
and so we look at seo in terms of
measuring results
on the on page side okay you're going to
have to
do some keyword analysis you're gonna
have to understand okay what volume
is you're gonna understand how to get
the competition numbers
okay and you're gonna have to understand
what keywords to choose
okay so that in itself is a skill being
able to choose keywords based on
several metrics then you're gonna have
to be able to
ascertain you know what pages and what
keywords are driving traffic
and how those pages are performing
okay and then again the off page you got
different metrics like domain authority
or page authority
you have external links internal links
you have no
follow and follows and and a lot of
these little metrics related to off page
seo so you're gonna have to understand
what those metrics mean
and if you can understand what those
metrics mean and then more importantly
act on those metrics then that's what's
going to help you
improve your results in terms of seo
so again that's going to be the common
theme here so i'm just going to
highlight again those metrics that
you're going to need to understand
in order to better manage seo as a
channel
get on the on page side you need to
understand
the technicalities involved but
for example page load what's a good page
load time what's about page load time
from a keyword perspective what's good
volume what's bad volume what's good
competition what's bad competition
so if you can understand the intricacies
of the measurements related to seo
then that will help you improve upon
this big channel called organic search
so seo is the practice of getting
relevant traffic to the website okay
from organic search results so it really
is essential to stay up to date
and have a complete knowledge of the
latest algorithm updates and factors
that affect
search engine ranking so that's seo
let's transition to
search engine marketing also known as
paid search sponsored search google
ads bing ads pay per click
cost per click a lot of acronyms a lot
of ways to describe it
at the end of the day search engine
marketing means that hey you as an
advertiser have the ability
and have the opportunity to rank at the
very
top of the google search results now
it's different than seo because you're
actually paying for the placement
and so to be found at the top of the
search engine results
as a paid placement or sponsored ad
means that
if somebody clicks on your ad you're
going to pay google
x amount okay so unlike seo
sem is very fast moving and so
when we talk about fast moving we mean
that you're collecting a lot of data
very quickly
so sticking with the theme of what
skills should i have for search engine
marketing well
if you're going to collect data then
that means you need to measure the
results of that data
and so sticking with our theme of
measuring results you need to
understand first and foremost what all
the different metrics mean
related to sensor engine marketing okay
so i'm just gonna
rattle off if you will a few of the
metrics but the commonality here is
yes you can learn what those metrics
mean but you have to act on those
metrics
so one of the the main metrics involved
with search engine marketing is
impressions
so impression is just basically how many
people have seen your ad
okay so if your ad shows up on the
search results page
regardless of whether somebody clicks on
it or not you're going to get an
impression
okay so if you're getting a lot of
impressions that means a lot of people
have seen your ad
what's a lot of impressions well it's
subjective okay so
it could be a thousand impressions or
ten thousand impressions at the end of
the day
that's how many people have seen your ad
now more importantly
you have another metric called clicks
clicks means how many people actually
saw your ad and then clicked on your app
okay so if you have
100 people that have seen your ad and
one person who
clicked on your ad then you have a click
through
rate of one percent now when it comes to
google
ads and search engine marketing in
general you want to have a high
click-through rate especially on google
because that
does impact quality score so quality
score is another metric
you need to be aware of okay it's a
quality score simply a number between
one and ten that's assigned to each
keyword okay
so what impacts quality score
click-through rate is one of the
factors that impact quality score so
if you have 200 or
300 or 500 or a thousand impressions and
very little clicks that means your
click-through rate's going to be low
and if your click-through rate is going
to be low then your quality score is
going to be low
and in order to pay less to google you
need to make sure that your quality
score is good
so you need to understand the factors
involve a quality score
you need to understand impressions
clicks click-through rate
because if you don't have a good
click-through rate then how do you
improve that
so it's about measuring the results and
acting upon the results
those are the skills involved with
search engine marketing
and that's just on the click side you've
got the conversion side of the house
so you need to be able to understand how
to get conversions
and how to maintain a high conversion
rate so for example
if you have a hundred clicks and only
one conversion
that is a one percent conversion rate
okay fair enough
but what are you paying per conversion
what's the cost per conversion
okay and if that number is high like say
twenty dollars and you're only selling a
product that's say
ten dollars well then you got a problem
and so there's a lot of different
metrics involved with search engine
marketing you're collecting this data
very quickly
so you need to be able to react to the
data that you see
so that's the skill set really involves
search engine marketing
if you're getting the data if it's a low
click-through rate or low conversion
rate or high cost per conversion
or very low impressions you need to be
able to understand
how to react to what you're seeing and
what your data you're collecting
that to me is the primary skill bottom
line
with search engine marketing and there
are other skill sets involved don't get
me wrong i mean it's nice to be able to
write copy
because with search engine marketing
typically the ads
have very few characters involved so you
need to be able to
write a compelling ad to convince
somebody to click
on your ad and so
writing copy being able to understand
your target audience
those are all things involved with
managing search engine marketing but
really the key component here
is again measuring the results okay
let's
switch over to a traditional marketing
channel
email marketing you know one of my
favorites
you know listen we're all bombarded with
emails
uh and you know what it it becomes
cumbersome at times i mean it's easy to
just
disregard an email and so to me the key
here if you're going to do email
marketing
you need to have a certain set of skill
sets and so what that skill set
is is really understanding your audience
because if you send an email to a
certain set of recipients you need to
hope
that that email is relevant to that
audience
okay so you need to be able to really
identify
who it is we're sending this email to
and a recent study done by statista
stated that 49 of consumers really
like to receive promotional emails from
their favorite brands
so if you have a very strong brand then
email marketing
is probably a good channel for you if
you don't have a strong brand or nobody
really knows about your brand or your
product
or your business then email marketing
could be a little bit of a
steeper hill to climb if you will but
really
email marketing is it involves emails
that promote
the brand's products and services and if
you could target the right
audience or making sure you have the
right audience then
you got a good chance of having
successful email marketing campaigns
but when it comes to emails you know
it's like having a blank canvas you can
be as creative as you want as long as
you're talking to the audience so
the big skill set here again is
copywriting and having some
you know creativity involved with that
copywriting
saying the right things but not saying
too much the same time making the email
aesthetically pleasing as possible so
that when
somebody does open the email they're
going to be able to react to it so
you know writing copy with strong call
to action or really relevant copy that
really talks to the audience
i mean those are all keys for email
marketing in my opinion
also one thing we didn't bring up in
search engine marketing but it certainly
holds true with search engine marketing
as well as email marketing
and that's a b testing and so a b
testing is simply taking an original and
creating a variant
and testing the two to see which one
performs
well you could certainly do a b testing
with email marketing
that means taking a subject line that
has
traditionally worked for you or is
relevant for that audience and then
creating
a variant or different subject line so
if i'm going to send an email to 100
people
i'm going to send 50 people
one subject line and then the other 50
is going to get my variant subject claim
and why is this important because i want
to be able to see what people
react to okay so if i see the open rates
higher for the variant versus the
traditional
or the original subject line
then i know that this subject line works
and therefore i'm going to apply this
subject line moving forward and then
what am i going to do
i'm going to take it and test it against
another variant so you should always do
a b
testing on subject lines so the concept
of a b testing
should not be lost on any digital marker
okay whether that be seo
search engine marketing or email
marketing
so you should have an understanding of a
b
testing and of course going back to
measuring results with email you have a
different set of metrics
we already mentioned open rates so if
you send out
100 emails how many people open the
email
okay you want that open rate to be as
high as possible
and then when they open the email the
people click on that cta
or any of those links in the email okay
so you want a high click-through rate
and then more importantly when they
click on a link in the email they're
going to go to
a landing page you want that person to
engage with that landing page
so what's the engagement rate of the
landing page
from the email okay so
it's really important that you have an
understanding of all the different
metrics
involved with email marketing and again
how to react to that data
so if you're getting a low open rate
could it be the subject line isn't that
good possibly that's why you have to do
testing
if you're getting a low click-through
rate on the emails
that could be because the copy may not
be that great or
the design or the call to action or it's
not compelling enough for the
recipient of the email and then again
the engagement on the landing page
if you have a low engagement rate a low
conversion rate
you got to look at that and figure out
how to improve that
okay so you can apply a b testing the
landing page so there are always ways to
react to the data
regardless of what campaign or
regardless of what
digital marketing channel you're working
in
okay so that's the commonality here one
point on email marketing
is if you're going to measure the
results of the campaign whether you're
using
you know vertical response or mailchimp
or you know some other email marketing
platform you want to make sure you have
what we call utm tracking and if you're
using google analytics
having utm tracking or understanding
what utm tracking is allows you to
measure the results of that email
marketing campaign in google analytics
so that's another skill set you should
have being able to apply
your tracking to your digital marketing
campaigns including
email okay because if you don't it's
gonna be hard to measure the results
in google analytics so let's focus on
one more marketing channel here and
that's social media
so we all know social media isn't going
anywhere it's becoming more and more
popular
in fact you know offshoot of social
media is really influencer marketing
uh you know if somebody an influencer
has millions of likes on say
tick tock or instagram you might want to
engage with that influencer
and help you promote your brand or your
product
isn't that really what social media is
it's a platform whether that be
you know facebook or or twitter it's a
it's a platform to help you promote your
brand your product your services
and it's a chance for you to get to
message your user base your community
prospective clients people who don't
even know about your brand it's a chance
to build awareness
so social media holds a lot of different
uh strategies if you will in fact nearly
almost 4 billion of the world's
population
uses social media let me see there's
seven
something billion people in the world
well
that's a large percentage the majority
of the percentage of the world
uses a social media platform okay
in fact just like seo when you need an
seo platform there are plenty of social
media platforms
there's later there's sprout social
there's hootsuite there's buffer in fact
buffer confirmed that 73 percent of
marketers believe
social media marketing has been somewhat
effective or very effective for their
business
and that's promising because social
media in my opinion
having been in this industry a while it
can be a very fickle channel
meaning if you're trying to promote a
product or service on facebook
and it's very very going to be very hard
to pull that person away who's engaged
with their facebook feed not only
just to get them away from the facebook
feed onto your website but
then to turn around and allow that
person to try and convert
okay based on what you have on your
website so it's challenging enough just
to get them away from the social media
platform
let alone converting so that's why when
i say
very fickle but you know somewhat
encouraging if
buffers telling us that marketers
believe that social media marketing
can be effective and it can be effective
you just have to have the right strategy
so to me
one of the skill sets you should have if
you're going to be a social media
marketing manager
is being able to understand you know
what is the strategy here what are we
trying to achieve
when we set up a social media platform
or enact a social media campaign
okay and so that's really the first
thing it's really
understanding what platforms what's the
strategy here because if the strategy is
brand awareness
then what channels or social media
platforms if you will
work best for us is that twitter is that
facebook
so it's being able to kind of formulate
a strategy a plan if you will
for social media marketing because the
last thing you want to do as a marketer
is endlessly just post content for the
sake of just posting content
because just like any other marketing
channel you're going to have
metrics and social media is not
shy on the metric front okay so you have
reach you have impressions
you have engagement rate in fact every
social media
channel has its own set of specific
metrics whether that be
likes followers shares
uh reviews stars if you will
so it really depends on the social media
platform that you're using but at the
end of the day
you need to be able to measure the
results if you're posting
let's just say on facebook and your
whole
job or strategy is to entice engagement
meaning get people to share that
particular post
or act on that post then you need to be
able to measure the engagement how many
people
saw the post how many people engaged
with the post
okay and so just like any other
marketing channel you're collecting data
and you need to react to that data
but more importantly it's about
being able to you know put a strategy
together first
and then i would you know a skill set i
would
recommend you have is understanding all
the different social media platforms
that are out there
you know i just named buffer or
hootsuite or sprout social
they're all good in their own right but
they're all going to have different
features
so to me understanding what social media
platform works best for you
you want to choose a social media
platform that you know allows you to
control what posts
you schedule when you schedule them how
they're scheduled what platform they're
scheduled on
at the same time you want a social media
platform that's going to help you
understand the engagement that you're
getting from that platform
and you'll probably want a social media
platform that
allows you to quote unquote listen in if
you will
on what users are you know reacting to
in terms of hashtags
or what's trending on that particular
platform
okay so you want a listening tool if you
will
as part of that social media platform so
it's understanding what platform you
want to use
when it comes to social media marketing
it's understanding which strategy
that that platform is going to help you
when they enact
okay and then it's also that social
media platform that's going to help you
understand the data so you can react to
the data
so those are all to me the skill sets
you need as a social media manager
and then an offshoot of social media
is paid social so just like search
engine marketing
you can advertise on say twitter
linkedin
facebook on a cost per click basis
meaning
if you're showing your ad on linkedin
and somebody clicks on it you're going
to pay
for that click you're going to pay
linkedin or you're going to pay twitter
you're going to
play facebook so it's understanding
you know the skill sets involved with
paid social is understanding what assets
you can have when advertising on these
platforms
you know can you use video on linkedin
or facebook
um you know can you use what type of
images and you know how big do those
images need to be
and can you have wording on those images
or what are the guidelines involved with
having images as part of your ads
so having a full understanding of the
types of assets that you can run in
terms of
your advertising on social media is very
important in my opinion
because it's always changing and you
want to be able to put the best asset
the best message you want to put your
best foot
forward when advertising on social media
and of course when you do advertise
again a whole nother set of metrics
you know how many people saw your ad how
many people clicked on your ad
how many people engaged with the landing
page how many people converted what was
the cost per conversion so
all of those are metrics that we covered
in search engine marketing
they apply with paid social so
you have the opportunity on paid social
you have the opportunity on social media
to really get your message out there
it's really
understanding what kind of data you're
collecting
what are the results of the ad or the
post
and how do you react to that and that's
really the common theme
with digital marketing skills if you're
not a big fan of numbers you're not a
big fan of excel if you will or
spreadsheets
if looking at a mountain of data scares
you
well then you might want to think
otherwise when going into digital
marketing but if you want to embrace the
data
then digital marketing is really a great
career
because if you can get the data and you
know how to react to the data
then you can be successful in any
campaign you run
all right that should do it for today
thanks for joining look forward to
reaching out to you
for more of these uh webinars
uh feel free to email us or go check out
our website at simplylearn.com
thank you so much and i'll see you soon